hey guys Pete here so today I'm gonna
talk about some spin-off or prequel news
for Game of Thrones we talked about this
almost a year ago when we first found
out that they were probably going to be
putting something into production since
then we heard that there were four
spin-offs officially in the early stages
we got a blog post from george RR martin
himself a little bit after that saying
that there are actually five and not a
whole lot of info at that time we did
find out who the original four people
that HBO had working on it was but not
the fifth and that's what we found out
this week we found out that Bryan cogman
who was or is I should say an executive
producer and writer on the HBO series is
working on the fifth one and he's
actually working pretty closely with
George RR martin george likes to call
them successor shows or prequels he says
they're not sequels HBO has said that
they will have none of the characters
from the series that's running now the
you know the main game of Thrones TV
show and that it won't be spun off as in
like another character will go off and
you know like The Adventures of hot pie
or whatever you know I mean it's gonna
be drawn directly from the source
material that's already there and since
they're prequels were assuming that most
of it will be coming from the world of
Ice and Fire or stories that we've heard
about in flashbacks because we also
heard at the time that we heard there
was five people that Robert's rebellion
wouldn't be happening George RR Martin's
said that he wasn't interested in doing
that right now because everybody knows
how it ends a little bit of a bad
argument I think because we watch World
War two movies all the time and we know
who wins in those as well but he wasn't
into doing that one and he didn't want
to do Duncan egg and that's actually
pretty significant in this latest
announcement and I'll get to that later
so as mentioned HBO hasn't told us
anything about any of them and we don't
really know for sure how many of them
will get made like we figure at least
one of the five will get made into a
full-on TV show just like Game of
Thrones that'll be on HBO
but it could be multiples it could be
spread out over time we don't have any
idea about that at all what george RR
martin said was you should not expect to
see all five shows though at least not
immediately as much as i might love the
idea
he wrote this on his blog and said we
could possibly see two or even three
make it to the pilot stage with one
series emerging on air in 2019 or 2020
and the others maybe later if they come
out as well as we all hope so that is
pretty freakin interesting if you think
about it because right now we're not
expecting Game of Thrones season 8 to
air until 2019 so the timeframe he laid
out here albeit he doesn't really know
would put one of them coming out right
after season 8 and that would make the
most sense for HBO TIFF season 8 is epic
as it's expected to be the momentum will
be right to start another one right then
I mean I don't think any of these really
would be as popular as the original it
just doesn't usually work that way but I
think that they could keep a strong
strong fandom engaged as long as they
make it as high-quality as Game of
Thrones has been now I know a lot of
whining fans are out there going what
are you talking about Game of Thrones is
terrible now I hate the way that it is
well you know guess what there are no
shows on this level as far as production
and stuff and yeah there's problems with
Game of Thrones and there always has
been frankly but it's entertaining a
[ __ ] and there's going to be more
momentum at the time that season 8 ends
than any other time so let's hope that
they put something good together they
have good people working on it and Bryan
cogman is really interesting because he
sort of worked his way up through the
ranks from a writer to producer he's
known as the keeper of the lore that's
the way that george RR martin described
him so that's all good stuff like this
is the guy you want to be doing it and
he's also in charge of the history and
lore DVD extras which are some of the
best stuff that's associated with the
show when you think about it I mean we
learned a lot there we see a lot of
things
they were interpreted from the source
material and how they relate to the TV
show and I can't really think of any
problems I've had with those so yeah
that's that's that's definitely a good
thing to have on your resume as far as
I'm concerned so we also know that
george RR martin has still not put out
the winds of winter and that is
definitely stressful for the book crowd
but we did find out that he's gonna be
putting out his targaryen history which
he was not supposed to do until after
the winds of winter was done and a dream
of spring was done but he decided to
break it up into two volumes and we're
actually gonna see Volume one either in
late 2018 or early 2019 now a lot of
people have been talking about this this
change in direction I mean a lot of
people are mad obviously and I see where
they're coming from it has been too long
since the last book in a Song of Ice and
Fire the theories are getting to be like
you know the theory makers are restless
out there it's just like you know
everybody's angry at the TV show because
they don't have anything else to
concentrate on it's a bad situation for
book readers I would say you know we've
had little things coming here and there
but it's been a long time since the last
main book came out and what's not
knowing when it's gonna be and having
like you know different deadlines come
and go it's definitely been a rough
patch of years and it could go on longer
let's be honest when you hear that he's
putting out a different book instead
that can put off some alarm bells but
you know he had most of this book
already written and that's the idea that
he's going with you know he already had
this almost done so basically what
happened was is when he wrote the world
of Ice and Fire
he started really I mean you got to
imagine that writing fake history is a
lot easier than writing actual you know
epic fantasy fiction so this is probably
like a good break for him you just have
to you don't have to make it anything
other than you know you have to explain
what happened you just have to tell the
story and the way he does that is
through maesters and of course fools as
well but either way you know what I mean
it's it's easy
you're writing for him I would imagine
so when he was writing the world of Ice
and Fire he started writing a lot about
the Targaryen Kings and then he had so
much material left over it wouldn't fit
in the book so from what I've read that
he's had like like 200,000 words cut out
from the world of Ice and Fire
what's his just sitting around and we
also knew that whenever he wrote The
Princess and the Queen the greens versus
the blacks the dance of the Dragons you
know they cut out a ton of that to to
make it fit in the anthology that it was
in so he already had a lot more written
about the dance of dragons as well so
what's interesting about all this is
that Martin said that Hoglund is going
to be working on a very important part
of around a very important time in
Westeros so this would seem to go
hand-in-hand with Targaryen right we had
we know that fire and bloods coming out
and we know that that covers from egg on
before Aegon but I mean all the kings
that were there up into a certain point
so what does it all mean well I think
what my thinking is and I've read this
from a few different people who know a
lot more than I do
I think this really points to them doing
dance with the Dragons
I think it's probably the best idea when
I made my prequel video so long ago when
we first heard out the only first heard
about it I said that I thought that was
a great idea except for the fact that
the dragons are expensive well a couple
months ago I watched Linda and Ellie OHS
video about prequels and they made a
pretty compelling case for why this
could actually work and why it doesn't
need as many dragons as you might think
of course they know way more about this
stuff than I do since they worked on the
world of Ice and Fire they co-wrote it
with George and so I take them I mean it
they made a good argument it made sense
it made more sense actually something
than some of the other ones that they
were talking about and if he's not
talking about the dance then it almost
has to be the conquest but you would
think that maybe somebody else might
have picked up on that I I don't know
you know what I mean but Game of Thrones
the TV show has made a great DVD ex
about the dances of the dragons so it
submits a material that cogman would
definitely be familiar with and most
fans are I mean it's you know the even
though he said it wasn't complete in
what we got and the princess and the
Queen and the rogue Prince I mean
there's quite a bit there so you can
imagine it being a pretty good story
well two more things first the idea of
cogman being here is good because he's
already clued in to how everything works
in the game of thrones production world
and there's a good chance that he would
bring some of those people with him and
you got to imagine they did a lot of
trial and error until they got the
Dragons right and if you think about the
field of fire battle I mean that was
pretty on you know the visual effects
were good there and they could
definitely pick up where they left off
and just move into a whole nother level
I think but what I wanted to point out
beyond that is and I read this in an
article in Vanity Fair it was written by
the ASO hey I am moderator on reddit you
know the rich subreddit Brendan B fish
and he pointed out the fact that with
those books changing around that might
be the biggest clue because Martin has
said the reason he said he didn't want
to do Duncan egg was because he didn't
want the TV show to finish the story
before he did so he didn't say that he
didn't think Duncan egg would be good TV
he said that he wanted to write the rest
of the stories first and then they could
think about something like that so if we
look at this he may be shifting to
wanting to have control of the end of
the story he's never really said about
whether how he feels about the TV show
but anybody can guess that if you have
something you've been working on for a
couple decades and somebody else gets to
finish telling the story that's even if
you tell them what to do it's not the
same so he definitely doesn't like that
idea and you can't blame him even if he
thinks the show did a great job he would
have a problem with it I'm sure so this
is a pretty good train of thought to
Brendan B fish is following here when
he's saying that he wants to present his
own conclusion and that gives him a
chance to just he knows he's not gonna
get to other books done because season
eights gonna come and go you know what I
mean it's like it's kind of a way if
him to be involved with something that
can be his not necessarily his but can
be based on his story from start to
finish with a clear blueprint and to
work with someone who might really be in
a good position to carry that out for
him so I think it's cool
it could be a guns conquest like I said
I just think that's not as interesting
of a story the the dance has some
problems as well I mean Game of Thrones
is the best story I think I mean that's
the core of the Song of Ice and Fire
series and and that's why it's good but
these other things can be done well if
they you know they have the right people
behind them and like I said you know HBO
has not dropped the ball at all as far
as production value and budget and
everything else that goes into making a
really stellar TV show so I think that
this is probably our best bet to have
something that's really true to George
RR Martin's vision and I'm excited to
see if that's what's the case or not I
mean it might be a long time but I'm
also interested to hear what you guys
think as well so please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already I got
some I got a bunch of stuff coming out
I've been trying to put together a
couple different series I want to do the
character series first for season eight
so that'll be coming up next I wanted to
get this video out first though because
this is pretty big news everybody
wonders what they're gonna do whenever
Game of Thrones ends well it looks like
we're gonna have another good show I
mean we have people competing to make
one show that's gonna come out so that's
always good I think yeah so please you
know follow me over on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook we can interact
over there
and check out my patreon I can really
use your support I'd like to keep doing
a lot of stuff all the time but you know
how it goes it's a difficult way to make
a living so thanks for watching guys
I'll talk to you soon